locked in quarantine you may be
fantasizing about summer tanning in the
Sun or taking a dip in the sea but a big
question remains as the weather warms up
well the corona virus pandemic wind down
I hope I think it will be cause for
celebration if it does start to die down
scientists are divided some believe the
heat won't matter these viruses and this
one humans close enough together for it
to jump from one to the next others
point to a study at university of hong
kong that found the virus deteriorated
over time when stored in a lab at 72
degrees evidence from similar viruses
also suggest Ovid may transmit less
efficiently in the spring and summer
months
right now Australia and Singapore are
experiencing high temperatures and low
infection rates but that's not the case
everywhere dr. Anthony foutch II the top
infectious disease expert in the u.s.
says the corona virus will continue to
do its own thing and that there's no
guarantee the weather will come to the
rescue
Ian Lee CBS News London